it's great to be joined today by Cathy
O'Neil who's an author mathematician and
data scientists who recently published
the book weapons of mass destruction
about the dark side of big data Cathy
really great to have you on for people
who don't know what Big Data is and what
we're referring to let's sort of start
there what are we talking about well
actually it means really different
things to different people I think to
technical people big data refers to like
basically so much data that you can't
fit on a normal computer and you have to
go to the Amazon Cloud to really deal
with it it sometimes it means too
technical people social media data
specifically things like clique streams
and such but I think um for the most
part in the book I wrote it was really
more of a marketing term the term that's
used by salespeople and marketers to
talk about big data products and big
data algorithms and some of those
algorithms really don't have that much
data behind them talk about that what
explain how it you could have an
algorithm that doesn't have much data
behind it and sort of how something like
that might come to be marketed in a
particular way what's the sort of
mechanism by which this comes to be well
so for example I talked to about the
value-added model for teachers in the
book and for a given teacher the amount
of data being collected about her
students probably you know the scores
for the previous year and the year that
the teacher teaches them information
about the class size and makeup of the
class and which school district it's in
and you know things like whether they're
how many kids that have a have a free
school lunch which is a marker of
poverty a proxy for poverty so you know
not that much information for a given
teacher but of course if you collect
that across an entire school system it
gets to be what I would term
medium-sized data and but that I think
the more important part is that the
algorithm which is supposedly assessing
a teacher's ability really is marketed
as like inherently objective and fair
because it is an algorithm and that's
the kind of sort of almost a social
construct of what an algorithm
is that I try to talk about in the book
I'd love to hear a little bit more about
that I mean I think that that's sort of
the most superficial level if the
algorithm is developed by humans then
it's going to be subject to the biases
of those who created the algorithm but
I'm guessing there's more to the ways in
which these algorithms that are part of
big data can be inherently biased yeah I
mean you've you've picked out one it's
absolutely true so like you know anytime
I build an algorithm I choose what the
data is and what the data isn't I also
choose what the definition of success is
and I optimize to that definition of
success which might not be your
definition of success so I'm if I'm
evaluating something that will happen to
you I will decide what success looks
like and that's absolutely true in the
case of the teacher value-added model
the mistake is actually much deeper and
much stupider the mistake is that you
well I mean first of all the data going
into it is almost entirely focused on
test scores and the extent to which a
given teacher raises their students test
scores above what is expected and
there's a lot to unpack there but it
comes down to the fact that it's really
hard to guess what a student should be
getting so it's difficult to gauge what
expected scores look like it's also a
very noisy process to actually take and
test because you know kids can do better
or worse on a test depending whether
they just had lunch or not or how cold
it or hot it is in the classroom so
there's a lots of uncertainty both in
the expected score in the actual score
and then you're actually putting you
know assessing teachers based on the
difference between those two things and
if you imagine a classroom having the
size of 20 or 25 kids it's a very small
sample size with lots of uncertainty so
in the case of the value-added model for
teachers it wasn't so much faulty which
by the way it was faulty but the real
problem was that it was almost
statistically meaningless the date the
the scores for a given teacher would
vary wildly even within a single year I
talked to a teacher who got a 6 out of
100 one year and a 96 on a 100 the next
year we think we changed his methodology
so it was and there's more evidence that
I could go into about how statistically
random
it was almost it was actually almost a
random number generator but yet people
trusted it and believed in it because it
was marketed as trustworthy and
inherently objective and that was what
was really getting to me because as a
mathematician I would like mathematics
not to be weaponized like that I would
like mathematics in fact to be used to
clarify things rather than to confuse
people in the second part of our
interview we're going to get into some
other specific ways in which the use of
such data can actually have hugely
negative repercussions but to get to get
us into that sort of can you talk to us
a little bit about for the average sort
of Western person who engages with
culture and society in sort of average
ways uses the Internet as a consumer of
media buys products from a variety of
retail and online stores etc how is the
average person either participating in
maybe unknowingly in the collection of
data or being targeted based on
algorithms and data that have been
collected
well that question because it was a well
phrased question and and the answer is
the average person is probably
benefiting my ally from this whole thing
they are having they're constantly being
surveilled online and so your purchases
and your searches and everything you do
on Facebook and everything you do on
Twitter and all your interactions and
and stuff offline as well you're voting
and any kind of arrest records you might
have or any other kind of public records
about you they're all being collected by
data warehousing companies like axiom
and they're being used to tailor your
environment online to what they think
will essentially what will they think
will result in you spending the most
amount of money because they are the
average person is somebody who has some
amount of money in their pocket and can
be enticed to buy certain things or to
think certain things so buy certain
things by you know companies that are
selling you things or think certain
things about political campaigns that
are trying to convince you of things at
the other end of the spectrum though and
this is something that I realized only
after having worked as a data scientist
in a startup company like predicting
people's clicks and
purchases online for more than a year on
the other side of the spectrum like
there really are predatory devices at
work and when I say devices I really
mean the technology that I myself was
building when you think about in fact
the way I sort of started to really see
the dark side of being data like was
when I when a venture capitalist came to
my company and talked about his sort of
grand vision of the future of online of
online targeting and he said to us at
the company he said that he was looking
forward to the day when all he would
ever see were trips to Aruba and jet
skis as advertisements and he would
never again have to see another
University of Phoenix ad because those
aren't for people like him and I and you
know people around me laughed but I was
shocked actually I'm a very naive person
actually but I was shocked because I
still had this kind of unreasonable
expectation that online culture was kind
of a democratizing force and that we
would all have access equally to
information into really good information
and that was kind of the the nail in
that coffin I mean that was back in 20
2011 I guess that that happened to me
and I started looking around and
realizing that it was in fact a sort of
by design that we were creating siloed
and segregated environments online so
that people would only see what they
were told to see and this for again for
the most part the average person
probably benefits in my all the ways
from this although they're also shunted
into like smaller and smaller echo
chambers but at the very bottom of the
of the spectrum we have people who are
preyed upon by by for-profit colleges
and payday lenders which is something
I've learned more and more about and was
more and more disgusted by let's pick up
our conversation there we have been
speaking with kathy o'neill author
mathematician and data scientists the
book is weapons of mass destruction
tomorrow on the program we're going to
look into some of the specific ways in
which big data can actually lead to
amination we're continuing our
conversation with Cathy O'Neil she's an
author mathematician and data scientist
who recently published the book weapons
of mass destruction about the dark side
of big data
so yesterday Cathy we focused on what is
Big Data and the ways in which the
average sort of user of media and
technology is either feeding into the
collection of data or being targeted or
sort of being influenced by it in
different ways
let's now dig into some of the examples
you've talked about in the book feel
free to start wherever you want really I
know there's many examples talk to us
about some of the ways in which Big Data
may lead to sub optimal decisions or may
even be discriminatory right well I'm
going to start with sort of picking up
from where we went yesterday with the
teachers because I think I learned a lot
from that one example it's a very rich
example because not only did the
teachers were they sort of being
assigned it slightly in a meaningless
statistically meaningless scores but
they actually had no power to fight back
and I think that this lack of appeal to
Big Data was one of the sort of
characterizing forces for what I later
termed a weapon of mass destruction they
didn't get to understand the algorithm
this is how they were scored and even if
it was a mistake which I think it
sometimes was and we have evidence that
it sometimes was even with mistakes they
weren't able to change their score there
was no real accountability of the
algorithm and that is a general rule I
looked into it I found that there are
algorithms that send police to certain
neighborhoods basically when they find
that a lot of arrests were being made in
a certain neighborhood the algorithm
would send more cops back to that same
neighborhood it whether or not the
crimes were violent or not whether or
not the the other neighborhoods actually
had criminals but were being arrested
for them so it was basic and based in a
large part on faulty data and biased
data that these algorithms were being
treated as unaccountable sort of voice
of God we also had also found algorithms
that were being used by judges in
sentencing people and they would
sentence people for longer if the
algorithm gave them a higher risk score
which risk I should say risk of
returning to prison so it had this crazy
effect of keeping people in prison
longer and possibly making them more
likely to come back because of their
high risk score so it was creating its
own kind of reality so let's I think
those last two examples are super
interesting because you can really
observe the sort of self-fulfilling
prophecy nature of some of these
algorithms the algorithm purports to be
this sort of objective lens through
which we're just looking at data and
making what would seemingly be logical
decisions the police example is one
where you send more police to a
neighborhood that an algorithm has
determined has more crime taking place
it's possible that that's already
because it's a more heavily policed
neighborhood and what happens when you
send more police to a neighborhood
unless there is effectively no crime
more police more police eyes in a
neighborhood will lead to police
observing more actions which may lead
them to make arrests and it creates this
never-ending feedback loop doesn't it
yeah the thought experiment I like to
give with this example is like imagine
if the police had all been sent to Wall
Street after the financial crisis and
they'd been ordered to like to arrest
the bankers and to go through all their
pockets looking for cocaine or other
kinds of illegal substances they would
have found a lot of criminals and and
the algorithm would have said hey go
back to Wall Street police because after
all all criminals are and then we would
have had like a constant feedback loop
sending people back to Wall Street but
that's not what we as a society decided
to do we chose to keep the police in
essentially poor black neighborhoods and
that's where they are that's where
they're finding people to arrest so it
is a self-fulfilling prophecy and that's
exactly the kind of thing that I worry
about with algorithms algorithms create
they don't just predict the future they
also create the future it's even more
clear when you think about
some of the other examples in my book
where you have people who are considered
like unlikely to be good job candidates
and they are shunted away from from
those those those jobs and then you have
people that are expected to be bad
credit risks and they were they're not
given credit or they're APRs are very
high or they're considered bad insurance
risks and they have to pay extra for the
kind of insurance that most people don't
have to pay that much for and what you
can see is if you if you add that all up
the cumulative effect is that people who
are considered losers on under these
systems are actually forced to be losers
under these systems because they're
there they look like people that don't
have that won't do well so they become
people that won't do well because these
decisions are made based on that premise
and that is what scares me the most and
what I think is actually happening is as
long as these algorithms are allowed to
sort of go unchallenged unaccountable
we're actually gonna see an increasing
effect algorithmic effect of inequality
and we already have a lot of inequality
in this country but I think these
algorithms are going to make that happen
even more quickly
what could even be called a solution to
what it is that you're observing and
writing about in the book I mean how can
you how do you even start to approach
fixing the inherent problems with use of
data in this way
well I the reason I wrote the book is
because I think the very first thing we
need to do is as a society stop trusting
stop blindly trusting algorithms to be
fair algorithms are not inherently fair
they are built by their creators for the
sake of their creators so we have to
demand as a society that we get to
inspect the algorithms like what are
they
optimizing society to and is that good
for society I think a simple example of
that not so simple but simple enough is
Facebook's algorithm Facebook's
algorithm optimizes engagement with
Facebook which is another way of saying
how long we stay on Facebook and we can
see why that makes sense for them
because the longer we stay on Facebook
the more times we click on ads and they
get paid for that but it that doesn't
mean
that necessarily translates into
something that's actually good for
society we've been speaking about a lot
of the material that's in the book
weapons of mass destruction and we've
been speaking with the book's author
Cathy O'Neil who is also a mathematician
and data scientist Cathy super important
topic and I really appreciate you
joining me today to talk about it thank
you very much for having me